hello everybody and welcome to part one
of let's play penumbra overture as I
understand this is the first game of
this series
oh that not me uh-uh not me either okay
normal I don't want to die too much not
just be boring
whatever yes my story began in February
year 2000 but my call to this allegory
uh-huh I'm not gonna make the same
mistakes my father may oh sure you're
not how would vanish from my mother's
life before I was even in it ah so when
he sent me a letter a few days after
mom's funeral
yeah first I've ever heard Daria pity he
was dead sure writing from beyond the
grave must be a genetic habit in my
bloodline yeah that seemed normal
it's less to contain the key
instructions please forgiveness don't do
it I figured the dead don't have the
excuse for absolution yeah that's right
she's prophetic passing which he
inexplicably expected to come any day
aha clearly averse to explanations my
father prefer to leave directions to a
bank on Mayfair Mayfair hey that's where
Daniels Frankie deposit boxes huh sofas
executive of course I went as he knew I
would uh-huh
I discovered that despite the evidence
we've been legally declared dead almost
thirty years ago
I'm sure that the old book of collection
and notes I found had in the eyes of the
law been mine all this time never trust
the law
my father's instructions were to burn
the documents no further question yeah
that's why soon as his error no man's
immune to the shameful trappings of
curiosity and my humanity got the better
of me your humanity the University I
taught her was world renowned for two
things physics and linguistics I
represent the first and the man who
stood the second was stumped by our
recent acquisition uh-huh the book was
in decipherable sure it was the notes
how it showed a location somewhere in
uninhabited northern Greenland sounds
good to me it took me almost a year to
the last flight I'd ever take hmm as I
watched civilization disappear along
with Heathrow I realized my father had
disappeared three decades ago for most
of the day
I've considered in turf what it was that
I was leaving we landed on a strip of
ice a few big white and within minutes I
was pulling away from the chaste boat
beginning the 12 hour journey that would
lead me into my past 12 hour journey
into the game come on yeah all right oh
uh window yeah whiskey
I almost docked still not gear all right
all right yeah yeah gimme MA Jake and
mules sounds good to me
legitimate uh yeah he's that ah
why can't I what's going on what's going
on yeah uh-huh yeah torch
yeah that's English for flashlights yeah
I know my still okay something's going
wrong
okay I think I get it aha
there's a look mode seems kind of
unintuitive but what do I know
locked up my valuables ah yeah give it
yep mine give no I did
gimme good guy my gammy Garrett is all
right batteries who needs them
my flashlight runs on manliness oh that
oh yeah get out of the way Cher come
here
nope an asset sale something to remember
me by
don't know what fisherman's wife praying
in bed catch needs safely please be able
to come five week like last time huh
longer this time yeah sure you do
right still well in the eyes little
tryna take care of my love oh you two
all right yeah I got action op more
whiskey don't eat that
ya hear fish all right gimme gimme uh
coat fancy weather racing stuff gimme
gimme
yes
map
what's this to do nothing not a thing
right
what do I do knapsack can a soup BAM
jumping up
what we got here bucket bucket go right
at the window we got and answers I'm
just looking for action honey daddy duh
alright oh I see I'm so smart so smart
only took me five minutes to figure out
oh yeah nope that wasn't aha
yep get going as I stepped off the boat
all right now
snow yeah it's cold but I'm Way too
manly to be bothered by that bring it on
uh-huh it's a dead animal soon as I get
my hands on it now what's that run yeah
come on now he's sending to break it how
about my fist flashlight BAM nope
what do we got a rock big rock but I can
lift it up so small rock ha I learned my
lesson from amnesia solve every problem
I throw in a rocket come on now shut up
wolf bamm-bamm aha so tough and handsome
come on yep yep yep Ariel up you go and
down I go
uh-huh uh-huh
yep thump uh-huh
shut up where am I
what's going on all right bring it on
come here
do it grow yeah ooh aah get out of there
oh we got some big ol some rod so I can
beat their faces in and monition
I don't need ammunition I don't even
need a gun just my muscles hammer
let me torch come here
get good i'ma beat it with my hammer
whoop oh I can't
aah BAM [ __ ] [ __ ] off barrel you get
some - yeah right we got let's go Oh
aah BAM yeah the way a hammer I said get
away hammer get good way there we go
Oh so tough now BAM [ __ ] boop boop come
on BAM everyone all right let's go
who wants some get out of here great oh
yeah take that you want some huh
yeah I'm not scared don't scare me get
out of here
barrel hmm what's this mechanism
oh that was a heavy door this Bank up so
smart
come on other way come up ah barrel
what are you doing got here ah yeah
there we go alright now let's try this
again
ah much better uh-huh yeah that's what I
thought bring it on whatever I was
descending into it was a hundred feet
below ground protected by two solid
metal hatches located in a remote Arctic
wilderness and buried beneath the snow I
didn't know what to expect but it made
me feel something I hadn't felt since a
child nevermind
ah who's there nobody yeah here we got
was that a map I did look at the map oh
yeah yeah right put flowing out of sight
mud but come here who's out there
oh yeah whatever
I don't need that yep Oh some night oh
yeah I like sunlight okay what's this
all I said it's not like it that thing
it's a it's it's a look at the thing oh
man clutching something unseen he is
strange and yet he is no stranger never
seen before still I know this man before
me is Howard I call him father yeah
that's weird
alright whatever yeah what the hell did
happen go crazy let's see yeah yeah
wounded and pansy
dynomite yeah sembei nuts yeah ice pick
reading glasses 7c ba ba ba uh chief NCO
M major that's your name oh whatever
what's on my to-do list where is it
there we ha
third do list another way out yeah sure
there is a break through the rock with
mop fist yeah your key always need key
Oh doors are so slow so much faster
Asian open and open and open nothing
back strin no that is oh yeah huh he
needs you another torch chest ah ah so
smart so I do so well in these games
uh-huh my favorite book let's see huh Oh
Baxter and Baxter oh I'm gonna blow
something up yeah string uh-huh
nitroglycerin of course sodium by sodium
carbonate not bicarbonate very specific
red phosphorus barium all right okay
what do we got here
nothing uh nothing God ah nothing yeah
nothing so I started using my muscles
and get the Georgia Oh a ah ha
what are you beef jerky yeah loving some
jerky get me oh yeah stuff at the bottom
close him oh uh sorry I got wimpy
all right bring it on oh shut up
uh all right whatever I'll play your
game
oh oh oh good good doggy
oh you've never been this scared yeah
right I'll shoot you scared I'll bring
it on puppy I got it I got it I got a
hammer you'll miss me yeah ah uh-huh
Oh who's your bad puppy yeah here
no one likes your puppy okay
hah yeah nothing like I thought no oh
that's not a door
is it the door yeah it's a door ah China
down no.1 note
give me a note no no no I don't see any
note ah okay that's enough nokey dokey
alright get ready to die puppy prepare
to be destroyed or run away like a
little girly girl that's what I thought
get out of here who wants some ding dong
all right I got to pause it here thanks
so much for watching and I'll see you in
part 2 a penumbra overture bye bye